when you duel like if you were me and
giannis were going to fight because
we're like [ __ ] it we got to get to a
duel bruh
the point of it it's all it's all about
you go randall's island
yeah yeah somebody at our duel
modern day duel somebody else world star
yeah check out this little factory wait
no i'm going i got to think oh sorry guy
i'll [ __ ] duel you yeah now it's just
fanduel yeah
[Laughter]
i got chris for 500. yeah giannis was
450. i
don't know i think he's a good bat so
with a duel what
the whole point of it was a man-to-man
thing like alexander hamilton versus
aaron burr
you take whatever it is five paces or
ten paces you know there's a referee
it's illegal but there's like somebody
there watching the point is just to man
up
and just say that you faced a gun you're
supposed to shoot to miss
a gentleman's duel is to shoot to miss
really absolutely apparently aaron burr
wanted to kill hamilton that's right
but that's yeah in the whole in the
musical they make it seem like he feels
really guilty but i think in real life
he did not give a [ __ ] right i think i
think
i'm glad he was hamilton missed and
hamilton was a was a veteran of the
continental army so he could have killed
him but
he thought his gentleman's tool so he
shot over his shoulder which is what
you're supposed to and then
burr killed hamilton so yeah that what
aaron berg wasn't necessarily
erin berg oh yeah sorry yeah aaron burke
yeah he's like a hamilton where are you
from yeah
jesus i wish he would
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
baseball players put weights on the bat
and then we just we're taking
we're all going to get it it's all going
to get edited out
um why are you giving your people more
work
i know we just say because something
good will happen after this
yeah we're just getting warm you know
it's funny 45 minutes in for
for for guys who were really smart back
then and those guys were really
enlightened the founding fathers
uh the the duel as a method to test your
manhood
is one of the dumbest [ __ ] things you
could ever invent
yeah it's like let's just put on
stockings and [ __ ] thanksgiving shoes
and
pace around in a field in weehawken new
jersey and then shoot to miss and shoot
at each other but to miss for some
with wigs on what are we doing just have
a fist fight guy yeah you know
just have just play a game of dodgeball
against each other yeah why don't we
just wrestle each other and see who
comes first
yeah yeah that's the loser you shoot a
load
you shoot alone you're back like i'm the
man yeah i'm the man in this situation
i came first yeah we should do a history
on duels because i'm
very curious how they started aaron
aaron burr was supposedly so he
so he killed hamilton and then he also
got in trouble
i think he got out of it but for treason
so it's like you [ __ ]
you kill you kill a founding father then
you get in trouble
for trees and i think then his career
just like fizzled out it went out
yeah well he was upset at um aaron was
upset with uh hamilton for such a long
time because he thought that
uh hamilton who was uh very famous like
writing all these essays about him was
the reason why he was losing certain
elections
yeah didn't hamilton have influence in
what is like considered now to be like
the the post yes yeah oh really yeah he
was
writing all this stuff and then he's
like you cost me an election he thought
he was gonna get a presidency and he did
it
yeah and then he ended up being a vp
but i guarantee you when he came at him
he's like yo i'm uh
let's go for a dude he was like yeah we
shout out we shout out yeah i'm gonna
talk a lot of [ __ ] we should have aaron
but even that's like that's just such a
run your fault [ __ ] person i ca
i guarantee you in real life we would
all like alexander hamilton better than
aaron burke because even that like
you cost me the election it's like it's
knowing you shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah no i didn't it's like look at
typical [ __ ]
you blaming ev all your problems on
everybody else it's your fault
look in the mirror but the mirror wasn't
hasn't been invented yet they didn't
have mirrors back then i think you just
have to look in a pond
you just hired a guy who looked like you
yeah they have it do they have beers
they definitely had mirrors after that
before they had guns
you know what's funny is they did the
duel and i think it was weehawken
yeah so which is where joe mackey used
to live he still lives there oh my god
i don't think it's funny that even back
then they were like no you take this
[ __ ] to jersey you don't do that you
don't do a [ __ ] fight in new york
you take your garbage [ __ ] yeah you guys
are going to do some dumb [ __ ] go to
[ __ ] jersey
spot of where the duel was and we
hawkins they're like they must yeah we
gotta go to a cute hunt there yeah i
don't think he was allowed to have duels
in new york
that's what i heard but um no it's
illegal what they did that duel was
illegal but some rules were illegal in
new jersey and then
oh they went to new jersey because it
was legal in new york yeah and then it
took a day for him to die like hamilton
missed
he did he was the gentleman and he met
that's right that's what he said exactly
and he wouldn't have missed because he
was a [ __ ] he was a
war hero yeah and burr [ __ ] shot to
kill like a little [ __ ] that he is and
then
it took a day for him to die he went
back to new york and he died like a day
yeah that
it must have sucked so much to be alive
back then you just bleed out for a day
that's how you die but yo if that was
you chrissy you probably would have done
the same thing right what do you mean
like let's say you got shot in houston
yeah or you guys shot in minnesota yeah
you'd be like just please get me on a
plane back to jfk
i don't care if i die on a runway in
laguardia just let me die
new york city i would start pulling fat
reserves out of my butt to stay alive
yeah well i
as soon as i got at the new york air
space my heart would start beating yeah
the plane and sip the good news is uh
the bad news is chris is dead the good
news is we got him out of the improv
which is all i wanted he didn't get
buried next to a funny bone
yeah oh god yeah can you imagine [ __ ]
someone someone gives you eulogy next to
a strip mall
yeah oh sorry guys we're serving
cinnabons that's all there is around
here
got it [ __ ] it'd be better dude if i
have a heart attack if it's in a mall
at a mall club that's all i just don't
want to happen i don't want to die next
to like a [ __ ] cheesecake
yeah i don't i don't i don't want them
to be banging on the door of a lakenta
yeah sam the show was 10 minutes ago are
you just [ __ ]
throat i just i'm in the closet with a
belt around my neck oh yeah
the way i want to go don't get my dick
out yeah
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild